Let's get started for today.
Let's start with a recap of
what we covered last time
because we're going to
be building very heavily
on Wednesday's concepts.
So we talked about
online reinforcement
learning where we collect a
batch of data with some policy
by running that policy
in the environment,
and then we try to use that
data to improve our policy,
and then we repeat this
process in order to continue
to improve from practice.
We talked about an online
reinforcement learning algorithm
called policy gradients.
And the update for our
policy looks something
like this, where we first
take samples from our policy.
This will give us N
different trajectories
sampled from our policy.
We will evaluate the log
likelihood of the policy.
And so this pi here is
representing a distribution
over actions given states.
And so this is looking
like the gradient
of the log probability of
the actions under the policy.
And this log likelihood
is weighted by the reward
that the agent got.
And so if you have
higher rewards
as an outcome of your
actions in the future,
then you're going to be
encouraging the policy
to increase the likelihood
of those actions.
And then lastly, we
introduced a baseline,
which we could define to
be the average reward, such
that we're increasing the
likelihood on futures that
were above average
reward and decreasing
the likelihood on actions
that led to futures
that were below average reward.
So you can think of this
as encouraging the policy
to do more of the
above average stuff,
less of the below
average stuff, and then
repeating that process
to get better and better.
Cool.
We also talked about how this
algorithm is fully on-policy.
So in order to evaluate
this, we actually
need to have samples from pi
theta from our current policy.
And this meant
that we could only
take one gradient step per batch
of data, which is disappointing
because then we'd have
to collect ton of data
in order to improve.
This brings up this
notion of having on-policy
versus off-policy algorithms
that can reuse data
from other past policies.
And we started to look at ways
to make an algorithm off-policy.
And in particular, we talked
about using importance weights,
where if we weight the
objective by the probability
of the actions of the
new policy divided
by the probability of the
actions under the old policy,
this is a way to get a
estimate of the gradient
for the new policy.
I should also mention
importance weights.
The math behind it is
very simple and very nice.
But it's important to remember
that this isn't a silver bullet.
This approach is only
suitable when the policies are
very similar to one another.
And if the policies
are very different,
then this ratio will get
very large or very small,
and you'll also just have a
worse estimate of your gradient.
So today we're
going to be talking
about a form of algorithms
called actor-critic methods that
build on policy gradients.
As part of this,
we'll be talking
about how to estimate
the value of a policy,
and then we'll introduce
an off-policy variant
of the algorithm.
And these actor-critic
methods are the basis
for algorithms
like PPO, which are
used to train language
models, and that
are used to train humanoids
and simulation and so forth.
So very, very useful
RL algorithms.
And then the key
learning goals for today
is how to estimate how
good a state and action is
for a policy.
This is called
policy evaluation.
It's a critical aspect
of actor-critic methods
but also useful more broadly.
And then also talk
about how to use
those estimates to form a
better reinforcement learning
algorithm.
So let's get started.
And to talk about
these algorithms,
we need to revisit some very
useful objects that we talked
about in the first lecture,
and specifically, this
is value functions.
And so a value function
is representing
how good a state
is if you're going
to follow a policy
starting from that state.
And you can think
of it as the sum
of rewards used to
writing gradients
starting from some state.
So we'll write
this as V pi of S.
This means that we're going
to be starting at state S
and then running pi.
And for a given state, this
is equal to the sum of rewards
if we were to start
at state t and go
to the end of the trajectory.
And here's the sum of rewards.
Now, this sum of
rewards is going
to differ depending on
what state we start at
and depending on what
policy that we're running.
And so this is going to be an
expectation under our policy.
Actually maybe it's easier
to write this as expectation
on the inside.
So this is an expectation
over the states St prime
and actions at prime that will
be visited under our policy
and conditioned on the fact
that we're starting at state St.
So we can think about the
value function as this.
Just in terms of math, what you
can think about this as is--
or just in terms of conceptually
or in terms of intuition,
if you have some
trajectory, and you're
thinking about the value of this
state, you can think of it as--
if we were to collect a lot
of different trajectories
starting from that state
from our policy, and then
we just summed up the rewards
from this time step to the end,
and then averaged over
these trajectories,
that would define the
value of this state
or how good the state
is for the policy.
Another useful quantity
that will be making use of
is called the Q function.
And this is slightly different
from the value function,
but very closely related.
And the difference is that
instead of just thinking
about the value
of a given state,
we're going to be thinking
about a value of a given
state and action.
And what this is referring to
is instead of starting at S
and then running pi from
there, if instead we
were to start at S, take
a particular action a,
and then run the policy, what
is our expected sum of rewards?
And so then you can
think of this as--
instead of a picture
like this, say
we had some State s
that we considered--
first we're going to
take some given action.
This may or may not have
been what the policy would
have been likely to choose.
This action could actually
also lead to different states
because the environment
is stochastic,
and then it's the sum of
these rewards on average.
So this is what V looks like.
This is what Q looks
like for a given action.
So here are some
pictures on the slide.
So if we start from
state s, run our policy,
we compute the expected
sum of the rewards
along these
trajectories, then that
gets us the value of a state.
And then if instead we take
action a first and then run pi,
then we get the Q values, and
it's just the sum of the rewards
if we had started with action a.
Now, one thing that's useful
to think about in terms
of how these two
relate to each other
is you can think of the
value of a state as--
if you take an expectation
over the actions
that the policy
would have taken,
you can think of it as the
average or the expectation
of the Q values
over all the actions
that the policy
would have taken.
And then one last object
that we'll use today
is thinking about how good
is a particular action
relative to other actions
that we might take.
And for this, we
can think about,
if you consider the Q value
minus the value function, that's
going to tell you, how
good is it to take action
a versus following the
policy at a given state.
And this is what
is the advantage
of taking one action versus
following the policy.
Good question.
So the question was, is there a
normalization between V and Q?
You can think of an
expectation as an average.
And so in that
sense, there is going
to be a normalization
because if you were to,
for example, try to estimate
this expectation with samples,
you would take some
number of samples.
If you only use these two
samples to estimate Q,
then you would divide
by 2, versus here,
if you're using five samples,
you would divide by 5.
Is there a way that you
can get from this equation
to the useful
relation on the slide?
Is that what you're asking?
Yeah.
We can write out first
what Q pi looks like.
So Q pi I of a given
state and action.
We're going to condition
on St, at because that's
where we're starting.
And then this is the expected
sum of rewards if we--
So a sum over t
prime equals t to T.
And then we're going to have
an expectation of running
the policy here, and
then a sum of rewards.
And then in terms of seeing how
to get between these two things,
you can think of this
as a sum of rewards
under at future actions
sampled from pi,
whereas this one at is
not sampled from pi,
but all future actions
are sampled from pi.
In this case, we're
conditioning on the action
that's provided as input.
And in this case, we're
sampling from the policy.
And so if instead you sample
the action from the policy
and then feed that in to here,
then you'll get this right here.
So to help you start thinking
about some of these quantities,
let's look at an example.
And so say that you are
this person right here.
You really want to learn
how to play the drums.
And your reward is 1 if you can
play the music in a month, and 0
otherwise.
So capital T is
a month from now.
And you have three
different possible actions
in your action space.
One action is to
sit on the beach.
Another action is to watch TV.
And another action is to
practice playing the drums.
And say that your current
policy right now is just
to sit on the beach, and
you do that for all states.
Now, my question for
you to think about
is, what are each of these
quantities for the action of a1,
for the action of a2,
and for the action of a3.
And so specifically you
want to think about,
what is the value function
of your current state
for this policy?
What is your Q
function if you were
to follow each of these
actions once and then follow
this policy?
And then what is your advantage
function for the current state
that you're in and for
each of these actions?
And you can assume that in the
current state that you're in,
you do not know how
to play the drums.
What was described as
for the value function,
for this particular
policy that's always
sitting on the
beach, the value is 0
because the person would
not learn to play the drums,
so that's the sum of expected
rewards for this policy,
for V pi.
For the Q function, if you sit
on the beach at the current time
step or watch TV, the Q function
will be 0 for those actions.
The Q function for playing the
drums at the current time step
would be 1 if that amount
of practicing is sufficient.
It's also possible that it
would be a bit lower than 1
if you, for example,
practice for an hour
and then sit on the beach by
following the policy afterwards,
it depends a little bit on
how long a given time step is.
And then the advantage function
is going to be Q minus V,
and so it's going to
be a positive number
for the action of
practicing, and it'll
be 0 for the other two actions.
So the question is,
if practicing is not
enough to actually
learn, would it be 1?
Would it be between 0 and 1?
Would it be 0?
It basically actually
represents the probability
in which you would be able to
play this, given that you had
practiced for that
amount of time,
and that probability
it could be 0.
Maybe this is really, really
hard after just practicing once.
It could also be
maybe for someone
who's extremely talented.
They only need to practice once.
And so that could be a
bit higher for someone
that's a bit more talented.
It depends on various
factors like that.
Along those lines, if you
think about the value function,
if you're playing a game
of chess, for example,
the value function
is the probability
that you're going to
win for a given person
and for a given game state.
So it's evaluating
how good is the state
for a particular person.
That's another way
to think about it.
So those are the
objects that we're going
to be using quite a bit today.
Now let's go back
to policy gradients
and see how we can
use value functions
to make this algorithm better.
So we talked about
a couple examples
on Wednesday of some scenarios
that we're dissatisfying
about policy gradients.
And the first was that if we
are trying to learn how to walk
and we have a policy that
takes a small step forwards
and then falls backwards,
we will push down
the likelihood of
taking a step forward
because we don't
necessarily know that might
have led it to fall backwards.
Now, if we actually
had some understanding
that taking a small step
forward was making progress,
was actually good,
was advantageous,
then we might be able
to actually increase
the likelihood of
that, and so this
is starting to hint at
some of the intuition
behind actor-critic methods.
And likewise, we talked
about this example
of trying to fold a jacket.
And we found that if
you have a sparse reward
and you only do part of the
task by folding only the sleeves
or flattening the jacket
but not folding it,
you aren't really utilizing
the trajectories that
are getting zero reward.
And similar to this
case, if we instead
understood that these actions
are advantageous for making
progress on the task,
then we might actually
be able to figure out how
to use these trajectories
in a positive way.
And so to summarize
here, policy gradients
don't always make an
efficient use of data
that we've collected.
And if we can try to figure out
what actions are advantageous
versus not
advantageous, we might
be able to make better
use of that data.
So the question was, if a step
forward is helpful or not,
is that going to be
negative or neutral?
In case of this policy gradient
algorithm, the trajectory
that we considered here in
the context of the batch
of trajectories, net
negative was below average
because the reward to
go is quite negative.
It's actually making backwards
progress in this trajectory.
And so it actually is
going to be pushing down
the likelihood of
taking a step forward
because the future
reward to go is negative.
And what we'll
talk about today is
algorithms that in
principle could actually
increase the likelihood
for taking the step forward
and decrease the likelihood
for falling backwards.
So how do we do that?
A lot of what we'll focus on
today is this piece right here.
This is what's
actually telling us
that we should push down
the likelihood if we have
negative rewards in the future.
And this quantity, it's
estimating the future
rewards if we take
action a in state s.
And so we can
think about it as--
in this picture right
here, it looks a lot like,
what is the sum of rewards
if we started right
here with state s and action a.
And then if we think
about this picture,
we were looking at this
quantity in terms of what
we observed in trajectories.
But what would be an even
better version of this quantity
would be to actually
use the Q function.
And if we could replace
this with the Q function,
then we would be able to get
a much better estimate of
whether or not we should
push up the likelihood
or push down the likelihood.
And so looking at the
slides right now, what we do
is, for a single
trajectory, we sum together
the rewards that we saw, which
was, in the case of the example
before, the rewards
were negative
because we took a small step
forward and then fell backwards.
But if instead what we could
do is actually run the policy
many, many times and get a
Q function for the state,
that would be the
true expected rewards
to go under the
expectation of our policy,
and this would be way better.
We'd be able to get a much
better sense for how good it
was to take that
action in that state.
So essentially the
form of the gradient
would be able to get
a much better gradient
if the form of the
gradient looked
like this, where we increase
the likelihood of the actions
for things that
have high Q values,
and we decrease the likelihood
of the actions for things
that have low Q values.
So that's a first step.
We also talked about baselines
in the previous lecture
where the baseline was
the average reward.
Should we use a baseline here?
So before the baselines
were the average reward.
And so in this case, if we
were to introduce baselines,
we could think about
what we might use.
And if we use the same
thing that we used before,
we could use the average
Q value, in this case.
So we could use an average--
maybe we sample some Si and
ai, and we average over those.
And what we had talked
about a few slides ago
is this is actually looking a
lot like the value function.
So we talked about the
value of a given state
is an expectation
over actions sampled
from the policy for that
given state of the Q
function for those actions.
This is V pi.
And so a natural
baseline would actually
be to use the value function.
And so instead of
having this be Q values,
we could actually use Q
minus V. And Q minus V
is what the advantage
function is.
And so putting this
together, we would
be increasing the
likelihood for actions
that have a high
advantage and decreasing
the likelihood for actions
that have a low advantage.
And so then if you think back
to the example of learning
to practice playing the drums,
the action of practicing
had a high advantage relative
to the current policy.
And so then we would choose
to increase the likelihood
for practicing and
decrease the likelihood
for the other actions.
Cool.
Another way to
think about this is
that better estimates of
this advantage function
will lead to less
noisy gradient.
And if we knew the true
advantage function,
then we would be able to get
a very, very good gradient.
Unfortunately, we don't know
the true advantage function,
and so the next question
that we'll talk about
over the next several slides
is how can we estimate
the advantage function.
So the question was, how
is this different from how
we're sampling in the
original policy gradient?
And so what we're using before
is we would take of one sample,
and then for a given state
and action in that trajectory,
we would sum the rewards just
for that individual thing.
And this is going to be a very
noisy estimate because we just
have one trajectory here.
We just have one data point
to estimate these rewards.
And now what we're
saying here is
that we're going to try
to get a sense for what
the advantage of this action is.
Now, one way we'll
actually start
to talk about how we
do that in a minute.
But if you want to
think about what
is the true advantage
of this action,
conceptually, if you were to
take this state and action
and then roll out the policy
an infinite number of times
for this action
versus for following
the policy in other
scenarios, that's
what would give
us the advantage.
So the question is,
in policy gradient
we got to where we
were by optimizing
the expected sum of rewards.
Does this also optimize
some objective?
So this is also optimizing
the expected sum of rewards,
and it's actually optimizing
the same exact function.
We haven't talked
about how to get A yet.
But if you had a perfect
A, this would be giving you
the correct gradient for that
objective, the sampling here
being used to sample
states and actions.
Is the baseline and average
over the current or an average
over all trajectories?
So if we set it to be
the value function V,
that would be an infinite
number of samples.
We haven't yet talked
about how we're actually
going to estimate a or
estimate Q versus V,
so we'll talk about
that in a minute.
But yeah, for V,
conceptually, that
would be over an
infinite number.
But I'm talking about, this
is the true value so far.
We haven't talked about how
to estimate the value yet.
So the question is,
is this unbiased?
It isn't biased.
You can go through the math.
I won't go through that
today for the sake of time.
But yeah, this is an unbiased
estimate of the gradient
if you have the true advantage.
Now, we will see things
that are biased later today.
So let's actually talk
about how do we use this.
And actually just
as a quick overview
of what the algorithm will look
like for this form of algorithm.
Before we had this loop
between running the policy
and improving the
policy, now we're
going to have an
additional step where
we're going to fit a model
that's going to estimate
the expected return.
And essentially
it's going to try
to estimate this a right here.
And so our new algorithm will
have a few different steps.
One is to run the policy.
One is to try to
estimate values.
And then the last
will be then to use
that estimate and the
data that was collected
to improve the policy.
And so this step will involve
estimating either V pi Q
pi or A pi.
And this step will
be similar to before
except it's going to use
these estimates right here.
So how do we actually
estimate these values?
So we want to estimate
this quantity right here.
And to start out, we
need to think about how
we want to get to A pi.
And we could try to
directly fit A pi,
although it's actually
a little bit challenging
to get direct supervision
for the advantages.
And so we're actually
going to try to fit V pi.
And the way that we're
going to get there is--
let's see, where
do we want to go?
We know that A pi of
St, at is equal to the Q
value minus the value.
And so one option is we could
try to estimate these two,
although then we'd still
have to estimate two objects.
And there's actually a way to
turn this into an equation that
actually only depends on V pi.
And that would be nice because
then we could just only fit V pi
and then derive A pi from
there to get the gradient.
And so to do this, we can
think about Q pi right here.
And this Q function, this is the
value of starting at S taking a
and then summing the rewards.
And so you can think of it as
the reward at the current time
step that you got
plus the rewards that
would come after that.
And in terms of the rewards
that would come after that,
you'll have some next
state, St plus 1.
And so you can think of it as--
there's some next state.
This next state could be
a few different things
depending on your environment.
So this would be sampled from
the dynamics of the environment.
And then after this
state, it's essentially
going to be the sum of
rewards starting at St plus 1
and following your policy.
Sorry, this should be St plus 1.
The sum of rewards
starting at St plus 1,
that's equal to the
value of St plus 1.
So we can write this Q value as
the reward at the current time
step plus the value at
the time step after that.
Now, we can't sample
from these dynamics.
But when we ran our
policy to collect data,
we did actually see one
outcome, one St plus 1.
And so we can approximate
this as the reward
at the current time step plus
the value at the next time step.
And then if we want to
estimate the advantage,
we can write it as the
reward at the current time
step plus the value
at the next time
step minus the value at
the current time step.
And so maybe I'll do
this in a different color
to differentiate it.
So now A pi of St, at can be
approximated as r, the reward,
that you saw plus the
value at the next time
step minus the value at
the current time step.
And so if we then have an
estimate of V for our policy,
then we can estimate
the advantage,
and we can just try
to directly fit V.
And so on the slides,
what this looks like,
we have Q. Q can be written
as the expected future rewards
which is the reward
at the current time
step plus the future rewards.
These future rewards can
be written as the value.
And so we can think of Q as
the reward at the current time
step plus the value
at the next time step.
So why is this an approximation?
The reason for this is
that there's actually
multiple possible next states.
And we're just going to use one
sample from this expectation,
which is the sample that
we saw when we rolled out
the trajectory in our data.
And if you want an
exact thing, you
would need to estimate
this expectation
with infinite samples.
How good of an
approximation is this?
So it is going to be a
single sample approximation.
The good news is
that later on we'll
see ways to use lots
of data to do this.
Well, so I guess
the first thing is
that if this is
very deterministic,
first, it's going to be a
good estimate because there
aren't that many futures.
If it's more
stochastic, then it's
going to be a worse
estimate, and then we'll
see ways in which we
can use data and take
lots of gradient steps in a
way that makes it not too bad.
So the question is, is
there any new interaction
with the environment?
So I guess we haven't yet
talked about how to fit V pi.
So we will talk about
that in the next slide.
So if you have some
trajectory this
will be like the St, at and St
plus 1 from the same trajectory.
So you need to use the
same trajectory for this.
And sometimes I forget
to put the pi on here.
And there is a lot of
reinforcement learning work that
drops the pis just
for simplicity,
but it is actually,
in some ways,
very important to have
A pi there because it
is estimating a value
for a particular policy,
not for any policy.
So the question is, why
are we choosing to estimate
V versus Q versus A?
It's just a little bit
simpler in practice.
But there are also ways
to directly estimate Q.
And actually we'll talk about
some of those ways next week
as well.
So we're just going to fit V pi.
And then once we fit V pi
we can get the advantage,
and then plug that into our
gradient for our policy.
We can represent V pi
as a neural network.
And what this will
look like is we'll
pass as input a
state and then it
will output a
single scalar value
that represents the value of
that state for that policy.
This neural network will
have some parameters.
So how do we do this?
So there's a few different
ways to estimate V pi.
So in the very, very
initial version,
like a vanilla policy
gradient, we just
used a single trajectory,
a single sample.
And instead of actually
learning a model
we just used that sample.
In principle, we could
also use many samples.
Unfortunately, if you were to
try to go to a particular state
and then take many
samples from that state,
that means that you
would have to be
able to reset the
world to that state
and see what happens if you
took many different rollouts
from that same state.
And unfortunately,
in many scenarios,
it's very hard to
reset the state.
If you are in
simulated settings,
sometimes you can actually
reset the simulator.
So there is sometimes scenarios
where you can do this,
but in practice, we
typically don't do this.
So since we can't
directly reset and take
lots of samples,
what we can do is
we can use multiple
trajectories that we had sampled
and just train a single model
on the original single sample
estimate.
And because the
trajectories that we have,
they will have some states
in them that are similar.
You'll be able to essentially
learn how to amortize the data.
So you'll see some examples
in the environment that
have very similar
states and have
corresponding future
rewards in them.
And with that
repetition in your data,
a neural network can have
a little bit more density
in terms of the rewards that
you'll see for a given state.
And so what this is
going to look like is
you can take your
data set, and you'll
have I equals 1
to n trajectories.
And each trajectory will
have time steps in it.
And for all of those
trajectories and time steps,
you'll also have
some sum of rewards
that you observe for that.
So you'll have
some sum of rewards
that started at t to the end
of the rewards of the states
and actions that you visited.
And if you aggregate all the
trajectories in your data set,
you can train a model
to go from the state
that you saw to the sum of
rewards that was observed
when you ran the policy.
And with this, you can
form a supervised learning
data set where this is
the label in the data set.
And you can train
with supervised
learning a model to take
as input this and output
this quantity right here.
And the number of data
points in your data set
will be the number
of trajectories
times the average
number of time steps.
So the question is, each
time your policy changes,
do you have to recollect
the data and refit this?
With this approach, yes.
We will see approaches later.
This is the simplest and
dumbest approach you can
use to fit a value function.
And we will see approaches
where you can reuse other data.
So the question
was, if we're going
to be running a
lot of simulations
or rollouts of our policy,
is it unreasonable to try
to learn some estimate
of future states
given the current
state and action?
Two things here.
If you have a very simple state
space, a very small state space,
you might be able
to store some things
and form an estimate
just from storing things.
You could also, in principle,
train a neural network
to predict what future states
would be given current states
and actions.
There are a set of
approaches that do that,
and they're called model-based
approaches and that they're
learning a model of the world.
And we will talk about those
approaches in a few weeks.
So this first approach,
run a bunch of samples,
aggregate a data set
of our future rewards,
and then run supervised learning
to fit an estimated value
function where you
can form an L2 error
between your predicted value
and the observed sum of rewards,
and then minimize
that with respect
to the parameters of
your value function.
And so what this objective
looks like is minimizing
with respect to your
parameters the difference
between your predicted
value and the example
or the sum of
rewards that you saw
in your data set for a given i.
And you'll do this for
all of the data points
in your data set.
And so this actually
can also be a sum over i
and t, just for completeness.
So that will be the objective.
And you can run gradient
descent on this objective
to fit a value function
on your data point.
Do we need to train a neural
network for every gradient step
in this case?
So this is actually different
from policy gradient where--
the gradient steps
here that we take
are going to be trying
to fit a value function.
And the value function
isn't changing the policy.
And so you can actually
take many gradient steps
on this objective to learn a
value function without having
to recollect your data.
So this is the simplest approach
for training a value function.
It's called Monte
Carlo estimation
where essentially you're just
running lots of simulations,
running lots of
rollouts, and then trying
to learn how to predict the
outcome of the future rewards.
Now, there's
actually an approach
that's better than this.
And in particular, when we think
about these sum of rewards,
maybe it's helpful to draw
a picture in this case.
So we have a bunch of
trajectories that we've sampled.
And in this case, what we're
doing is when we have a state
right here, we are summing
the rewards here as the value.
And as we're
learning this, we're
starting to learn what the
value of a given state is.
And this means
that maybe halfway
through training when we're
regressing to future rewards--
and if we start to get what is
a good value of this state right
here, then we could
actually try to use
our own estimate of this value
as the supervision target.
And in particular,
if we know that we
got a reward at this time step
right here to then get to here,
then we could actually use
that reward plus our estimate
as the supervision target
rather than just using
the sum of future rewards.
And so in particular,
the ideal target
is the true sum of
expected rewards.
This is equal to the
reward at the current time
step plus the expected
rewards at the next time step.
The sum of rewards
that the next time
step is equal to the
value of the next state.
And so in principle,
what we could
do is instead of trying to
regress to future rewards,
we could regress to the
reward at the current time
step plus the value
at the next time step.
And so we're actually
going to be, in this case,
using our estimate of the
value at the next time step
as part of the
supervision target.
So these are all for
a given trajectory,
and this would be your new label
for your data set for a given
state.
So the question is, how often
do you update these V pi's?
In practice, you can update
them every single iteration.
If it's really expensive
to update them,
you could update them less
frequently if you have
a really huge neural network.
But in practice,
typically, we update them
every single gradient step.
So we have these
bootstrapped estimates.
We refer to this as
bootstrapping because we're
actually bootstrapping off of
our own estimate of the value
function as part of
the learning process.
We formulate our training data.
We're then going to use
the same exact objective
to fit a value function.
Just regressing
to these targets,
we just have different
labels in our data set now.
And these labels are changing
as we run gradient descent
on our objective.
And so you often will
update your labels
every single gradient update.
So the question is, is this
based on one trajectory
or is this based on
multiple trajectories
where things are close together?
So this data set will be
over multiple trajectories
where i is indexing
over trajectories
and t is indexing over time
inside those trajectories.
In terms of this label, this
will be for a given data point.
And you're not going to be
running multiple simulations
from that data point,
but you're going
to be estimating what would have
happened from your future state
rather than a single
sample of what
happened in that trajectory.
And so with this,
you're actually
able to get a better estimate
of all of the possible outcomes
that might have happened
at the next state,
rather than just one outcome.
So you're asking, why is the
input to the value function
just S and not including
previous time steps?
Oh.
The ideal target for
our value function
is the sum of future rewards.
And you can think about
this sum of future rewards
as the reward at the
current time step, which
is a deterministic quantity plus
the future rewards conditioned
on our current state.
And so this is conditioned
on the current state
because the future rewards is a
function of where we are right
now, and it's actually
only a function
of where we are right now
and not anything else.
So the question is, does
this require that you have
a good initial value estimate?
Because if it's really
bad at the beginning,
then your targets
will be really bad.
There are some considerations
when initializing it,
although oftentimes
you don't need
to do anything super
fancy to initialize it,
and you can just get started
training on this directly.
You probably don't want to
initialize your neural network
such that the values are like
negative 1000 or something, that
would be bad.
But usually we don't initialize
our neural networks that way
anyway.
I don't know if I've in practice
seen any issues with this.
But in principle, you could
also start with a Monte Carlo
objective just to get
it in the right ballpark
and then continue with
this update after that.
So is this part of
backpropagation,
and is there a better
way to than updating
the labels every step?
So we'll be using
backpropagation
to optimize that
objective right there.
You could also think about
this as propagating information
backwards in time, which is
distinct from propagating
gradients through the network.
One other name for this is
called temporal difference
learning where we're
looking at the difference
between the future time step
and the current time step.
But generally propagating
information through time
is fairly distinct
from back propagation.
To summarize what we've
talked about so far,
Monte Carlo were supervising
with the rollout summed rewards,
whereas bootstrapping
were supervising
using the reward plus
the current value
estimate of the next state.
And if we look at an example--
and actually, yeah, I'll
give another exercise for you
to figure out.
So let's look at an example.
So we run the policy.
Maybe we just have
two trajectories.
In practice we'll
have more than this.
But say we have
two trajectories.
One of these trajectories the
final reward was negative 1.
The other trajectory the
final reward was one.
And along this directory,
before the final state,
the reward is 0.
My question for you
is, what estimate
would we get for two different
states for the value function?
And in particular, if we were
training on just these two
trajectories, and we use
Monte Carlo versus using
temporal difference
or bootstrap learning,
what would we estimate
the value to be
for the blue state
for these two?
And what would we
estimate the value
to be for the pink
state for these two?
So for Monte Carlo
in the blue state,
it's going to average out
the minus 1 and the 1,
and so this
prediction will be 0.
Does anyone want to
share another one?
Yeah.
So for the Monte
Carlo for this one,
this will be
negative 1 because it
will be supervised to
predict the sum of rewards
for the future for
this trajectory.
Anyone want to share?
Before we do that,
let's talk about--
do you want to do this one?
This is a little bit more
intuitive to go this way.
Yeah, so this will also be 0.
And then does anyone
want to do the back part?
Yeah, so for this one, it'll
see this blue one in the future.
This will have a 0,
and then this will also
be assigned the hat of 0.
And so this is an
example of where
Monte Carlo and the
bootstrap estimate
are going to be different.
And arguably, we get a
more accurate estimate
from the bootstrap
value because it's
able to look at its
estimate of the value
and actually aggregate
information across trajectories
more effectively.
Why the Monte Carlo is
minus 1 by the top right?
So the value for this one
is going to be minus 1
because the Monte Carlo
objective is supervising
to the sum of future
rewards that are
observed for each trajectory.
And so for this
trajectory, which is black,
it only sees the sum of future
rewards along this trajectory.
So it only sees negative 1.
And anything over here, along
this trajectory for Monte Carlo,
would have a target
of one because it only
sees the future
trajectories here
because it doesn't bootstrap
off of its estimate that was
using all of the trajectories.
So the Monte Carlo blue
state, it's going to be--
that exact state
is in the buffer
or is in your data set
for both trajectories.
And so it's going to
average the reward for them.
But this is like
the only scenario
where Monte Carlo is
going to get information
from both trajectories
because you have
the same exact state
in your data set
with two different labels.
Why is the bootstrap
blue state 0?
So this is also going to be
averaging the future rewards.
It doesn't have anything
necessarily special
to bootstrap off of.
And so for the same reason
that Monte Carlo is 0,
this will also be V0.
So basically everything
after the blue state
will have a value estimate
of negative 1 here.
And everything after the
blue state on the block
trajectory is going to have
an estimate of negative ones.
We should move on.
So one question you might
ask looking at this is--
there might also
be a middle ground.
So Monte Carlo is going
to have high variance,
but it is completely unbiased.
Whereas the bootstrap estimate
has much lower variance,
but it actually can be incorrect
because your current estimate
of the value function is
going to have inevitably
at least a small
amount of error in it.
And so there might be a way to
potentially balance this bias
and variance a bit more.
And one way that we
can think about this
is if we have our
trajectories, we
can think of the
Monte Carlo version
as using the sum
of rewards averaged
over those trajectories,
whereas the Tt version
is going to be looking
at the first reward
plus the value right after that.
So it's r plus V for just like a
temporal difference of just one
time step.
And you can actually interpolate
between these two estimates.
And instead of using
just one time step,
you could use n time steps.
So you could look at sum
of the rewards for n time
steps in the future before
the variance has increased
substantially, and then use your
value estimate after those n
time steps.
And what this would look like
is an equation like this,
where instead of just using
one reward right here,
and instead of using all
of the sum of rewards,
you can sum over the
next n minus 1 rewards,
and then use your value
estimate at t plus n.
And so this looks like
a sum over from t to t
plus n minus 1 r of S, a, plus
your estimate of the value
at t plus n.
In this case, this
is going to have
a lot less variance than the
full Monte Carlo, especially
if you have smaller n.
And it's going to
be potentially less
biased than just using a
one step temporal difference
bootstrap.
And so essentially you're
going to have more information
about the rewards that
were directly observed.
So this can be written as this.
And in this case, this
now becomes your target
for supervised learning.
And yeah, this is often
called n step returns
because you're summing
over n time steps.
In practice, the bootstrap
version, if you set n equals t,
this is full Monte Carlo.
Oftentimes somewhere
in between 1 and nt
works the best in practice.
And this can be especially
useful in scenarios
where you have very
small time steps
because if your time
step is, I don't know,
10 milliseconds
or something like
that, then very little will have
happened in between those time
steps.
If you have a very
long time trajectory,
can you use both of
these, you're asking?
Oh, yeah.
You could add all of these to
your data set in principle.
I think that typically the
high variance like labels,
the things that
are high variance
can deteriorate learning because
it leads to more stochasticity.
And likewise, if your
values are not very good,
then this can also
be a challenge.
And so in practice,
you'll usually
just pick one of these versions
and supervise with that.
In principle, you
could combine them.
But yeah, in practice
usually you don't.
One aside here.
So far we've been
summing rewards.
And we actually talked
in the first lecture
about how, in some
cases, we might not
want to just blindly sum
all rewards in the future.
And in particular, if
you think about scenarios
where the length of the
episode is infinite or very,
very long, then your
estimate of the value
can get very large
in those cases,
and so you might
not want to just
be summing over all of
the rewards in the future.
And so a simple trick
to handle the fact
that your estimates of
the value can get very big
is to weight your objective,
weight the sum of rewards
to be biased towards
the earlier rewards.
And the way that
you can write this
is, instead of having r plus V,
you can add a coefficient right
here.
If this coefficient is 1,
it's the same as before.
But you can set it to
something like 0.9 or 0.99.
And what this is
going to do is it's
going to say that I care
more about the rewards
at the current time step
and less about the rewards
at the future time steps.
Adding this discount
factor that's
discounting future
rewards is actually
can be viewed as changing the
decision process slightly.
So it's actually
equivalent to saying
that there is some probability
that the agent will
die at any given point in time.
And so this is
equivalent to saying
that with some
probability-- so say
gamma is like 0.99, in
this case, using this form
is equivalent to
saying that there's
a 1% chance that the agent will
enter some state that has 0
reward and stay there forever.
And so if you have some
original MDP right here,
the way that this discount
factor would change
the MDP is it would say that
with probability 1 minus gamma,
you enter this death
state where you can't
do anything else after that.
And the original probabilities
in the rest of the MDP
are all multiplied by gamma.
The question is, is there any
relationship between gamma
and these n step things?
If gamma is small, would
that change like what you do?
The way that you would
modify this objective
would be gamma to the n.
Possibly, I mean, I
think that they're all
interconnected in the sense
that the choice of gamma
might depend on the environment.
And, generally, if going to be
looking further into the future,
that's because you're going
to be in an environment that's
more deterministic or
a smaller time steps,
and that would also affect
the choice of gamma.
The question was, in terms of
choosing how far you look ahead,
does that affect whether
you're prioritizing short
versus long term?
In this case, it is
more a factor of--
so it doesn't actually
affect how greedy
you are because the value
function is representing
the sum of rewards.
And so these are
still estimating
the same exact quantity.
It's more a factor of
how far in the future
are you looking ahead
in terms of the rewards.
And it's more a factor of how
much is the variance increasing.
And if the variance
increases somewhat slowly,
then you can look further
ahead into the future.
If it increases very,
very quickly, then you
might want to use a smaller n.
So let's walk through
the full algorithm now.
So we talked about estimating
value functions, now let's
actually put this into practice.
So what we can do is we
can sample a batch of data
from our policy, then we
will fit our value estimate
to the summed
rewards in the data.
And we can do this by looking at
the rewards for a short period
of time and then the value.
So this would be the
equation for n step returns.
And then when we fit this
we'll run multiple gradient
steps on this objective
that's trying to minimize
the difference
between our estimates
and the observed future rewards.
Then once we have our
estimate of the value,
then we can use that to
estimate the advantage
of a particular
action by looking
at the reward plus the
value at the next time
step minus the value at
the current time step.
So this is telling us
according to our value function
and the reward we saw, how
good is the action that
was taken in the data set.
And then we can use this to
get a gradient for our policy
where we will be increasing
the likelihood of actions that
are estimated to
be advantageous,
and decreasing the
likelihood for actions
that are not advantageous.
And then lastly, we
update our policy
by applying this gradient
step to our policy parameters,
and then we can
repeat this process
to then sample a new batch
of data for our policy.
Now, note here we have
two neural networks.
One is for the policy and one
is for the value function.
This is called an
actor-critic algorithm
because one of the networks is
the actor, one of the networks
is the value function,
which can also
be called a critic
because it's criticizing
how good a state and policy
is, and that's our algorithm.
And coming back to
the examples that we
saw before, this
is something that's
able to actually
make use of data,
for example, that takes
a step forward and then
falls backwards because you can
actually learn from the data,
especially when you use
bootstrapped estimates,
that taking a step forward
is advantageous and has
a positive advantage
compared to other actions
that you might take.
And this is going to be
making much more efficient use
of the data that
we've collected.
So review so far.
We've talked about
policy gradients, which
is trying to do more of the good
stuff, less of the bad stuff
based on what you observe.
Actor-critic are learning to
estimate what's good and bad,
and then doing more
of the good stuff
according to your estimate.
And we can get a better estimate
by using a neural network
to try to explicitly
estimate the value function.
And then we introduced
this third step
where we are fitting this model
as part of the improvement
process.
We talked about
three different ways
to estimate value,
either directly looking
at some rewards, bootstrapping
off the value function,
and this hybrid.
And this is often referred
to as policy evaluation.